[Music]
uh so you guys know kelly clarkson
finalized her divorce terms i didn't
know that i didn't even know she was
here me too yeah uh
the countryside oh she was married to a
music management guy
how quick does she jump clean
dude
i know you're having the wrong because
you're married
i just heard she was paying a fat ass
check yes for settlement
what's your favorite song
since you've been gone yeah dude she
probably ripped it dope
i need a yellow jeep
yeah so check it out kelly clarkson will
be paying her husband 1.3 million in
divorce settlement 45k in monthly child
support and 115k
in spousal support the [ __ ] that baby
need yeah bro what about that's monthly
those last two numbers dude forty five
thousand dollars
wait she's gotta she's gotta pay nearly
a quarter million monthly no she's
paying 150 million pretty much yeah 150
million monthly how does child support
work because my dad never paid it but um
does the parent who's in charge of the
kid and has custody they're the one that
gets paid child support usually yeah
yeah does she not get the kid yeah her
she lost her kids i don't know they're
they're under it's joy custody but what
usually happens is when parents try not
to change the lifestyle of the child
they have to maintain everything that's
already happening so he's gotta have
just as nice of a house if she's keeping
a big house just the way it is yeah when
the kid is visiting the dad it can't it
has to be a nice house and eat the same
thing i think there should be a contrast
it's still down to what they agree give
her both balance like yeah so it's it's
down to what they're agreeing on if if
she really does agree that it has to be
that way then that's what she's paying
for and plus because she makes
exponentially more than this guy she
makes around 1.5 million a month and her
ex what the [ __ ] does she do she's got
her own show now i know but that's talk
show money still yeah well you're gonna
watch shows like like are they in the
drain and all that she crushed all those
music so she got like that licensing
maybe
yeah everyone's like whining about the
music industry yeah 1.5 you might be
investing into a lot of [ __ ]
1.5 kelvin clarkson got some bangers
though she got hold on let's please take
that back not for us
for like the rest of america people love
kelly clarkson i feel like talk shows
are gone like everyone watching netflix
i think they're gone for everyone but
people that like kelly clarkson to be
good anyway sorry well also um is she
just the host or does she own the show
and does she produce it maybe and then
she's getting ad revenue so like
i think her husband makes two million a
year how much do you think girls would
make oh he's somewhere there 70 grand
150 000 a year per month do we get his
like actual title yeah he's he's a music
manager he's probably managing her that
means he's probably taking like 20 off
of her [ __ ] he's probably got one or two
other clients which is how he met her
they're probably not successful let's
say five to ten a year how about a month
how much do you make some money every
month 10k
if she's making a million she's got to
pay that much he's making [ __ ] life
because that's how it works it's like
eight years 22 000 a month yeah i'm
thinking like 10 grand a month i'm
thinking like 100 200k a month you guys
are exactly right 10k a month that's
what he makes i did 10k i knew it was a
loser we know deadbeats bro you don't
know dude
if you've ever been around some divorces
some people get real petty and start
lying still hiding money
you know like right when the divorce
happened he could have dropped like
three clients it's like oh i don't make
that money anymore it's a huge drop well
i mean i guess he only has one client oh
it's her kelly clarkson no it's not her
it's the soundcloud rapper it's the
island boys blake shelton
that's a pretty big big client
blake sheldon and he only makes 10k a
month uh my girl when's the funny
oh they're together what about reuben
studdard is there not is anybody still
tripping what he manages
and he makes 10k a month oh no that's
bad maybe he has a lot of other agents
and he's just like in charge of his one
gig yeah that's what i'm thinking like
his japan tour or something yeah because
blake seems in my head blake's bigger
than [ __ ] kelly clark so i guess the
way that the cost worked out he's on a
show too yeah they had a uh like they
had a ranch like a farm together or
something and then she's gonna go move
and live closer to her career and then
they want to sustain everything so she
kind of has to pay money to him to
maintain
the scars wow he made so much money from
the divorce
it's the cost for the private jet for
the kid to fly oh yeah
yeah she can't be in first class that
would be a crime i think in the future
these kids the problem they're planning
to move the
the kid to like first class flights
later but for now they're probably she
better be in that barbie pink jet or
that is insane holy smokes i can't even
imagine that
i'm sorry i'm surprised she got that
money dude what's crazy is like uh
that's a lot of money yeah
yeah a star bro
old
clarkson
dog
but her show is like what like even
below like ellen and [ __ ] i think her
brand no she just signed on to do a new
show with snoop dogg that uh one of the
biggest talent shows like out there
right yeah it's the it's the american
song because for like talk shows like
when you watch morning talk shows you're
like who the [ __ ] watches this right but
it's like it's not for us i get it i do
soccer moms and stuff yeah yeah or even
like 60 70 year olds i get it but still
that's awesome they're watching my [ __ ]
out of it for sure yeah while they're
doing everything else it's not even
watching it just playing it yeah yeah
that's true yeah but her i think kelly
clark's branding is pretty freaking [ __ ]
maybe she's yeah maybe it's just my head
i'm so disconnected i feel like tv is
just dead
it's not dead for the boomers they watch
it they're used to it and they're the
ones that dictate policy in our country
yeah and they have more they're more
than than us
when i go to jill's mom's house the tv
is on but she's in the kitchen
yeah that is that is just the noise yeah
the noise in the house i know everyone's
got their own tv so if you own a samsung
tv and it's connected to the internet
you get like hundreds of just straight
up other channels that are just samsung
channels that's cool so it'll be like
kitchen nightmares 24 hours a day or
like kind of three is coming back like
in syndicate yeah yeah but it's like and
then like like vice has our channel we
should start a tv channel if you have a
samsung tv it just has a bunch of
channels some of these old shows are
probably cheap to [ __ ] just license
it yeah the questions
yeah uh that one's probably a little
expensive
i don't know if we go there which one
though the remake maybe mash yeah [ __ ]
like that what about andy griffith do
you think that do you think that's high
ticket i can wind you down after soon i
love lucy a huge phenomenon again they
like remade like three different movies
about it really she's [ __ ] great yeah
i love isla lucy for sure
oh yeah probably the ip just probably
ran out oh that's what you're asking why
there's like so many three remakes right
then i'm like it happens like that yeah
the licensing just like uh went up and
now there's a bunch of [ __ ] coming but
also it's it's also a thing on platforms
where because everyone's watching i love
lucy the um the newest thing they'll
just start advertising all the older
ones they have too i'd be like oh this
one's from 2016. this is that i really
enjoyed all of it because because i had
nothing else on the tv on my parents dry
cleaner so we always [ __ ] watched
that yeah
but then now i'm like why is that
it's popping on hbo i'm prime and
everything the new yeah the new uh
the new one oh thank you oh
[Laughter]
leave that in there guys
leave that in there
that's so much food
so like what do you guys how do you guys
feel about kelly clarkson's music do you
guys want to go around the room
oh she did that christmas one that was
hot um
[ __ ] i forgot what it's called all i
want for christmas is you eat a pizza i
think i gotta go with what's your i
think miley i all that music kind of
just measures part what's another kelly
clarkson came in like a wrecking ball i
thought stronger because of you since
you've been gone
those are pretty good for pop songs yeah
i think she's great she's great but dude
yeah that's pretty surprising right that
much
i mean she's single now maybe we should
hey kelly if you watch it
okay so let's say her ex-husband was
only making 10 g's a month right that
lifestyle is so [ __ ] different from
someone who's making a million a month
like how do you even keep up with that
he's also i think we're kind of like
semi-retiring and he's just gonna like
be a rancher or something yeah that
sounds like a good life yeah i mean
that's kind of time it's probably he's
playing the whole time yeah am i right
live on a farm that'd be pretty cool
obviously if you're if you're two
parents and you're split apart like that
and one is insanely busy with like show
business it's gonna cost a lot for this
kid to have like equal parenting you
know yeah it's just going to take a lot
of money right you got to move that kid
around all the time i think this kid is
going to be a rancher that's why you
think if you how many kids do they got i
think they have
the same one oh man to be that kid sure
i don't know this is gonna be a spoiler
my parents well my parents got divorced
my mom had custody of me and then my dad
would pay my mom uh 500 bucks a month
for child support yeah and then i
remember when i got kicked out a bunch
of schools and i ended up living with my
dad
um when i was 15. my dad was like um ask
your mom if it's cool if i don't pay
child support because i'm going to
support you when i ask my mom my mom's
like your [ __ ] sleazy ass dad would
say some [ __ ] like that and i'm like but
it kind of makes sense because you're
not gonna raise me
so why would she what's she using the
money for groceries i think she's just
probably just used to it and probably
like you know when you're like bitter
for sure and you get to check your money
like
that's nice you know because people are
just people you know so just like the
pettiness or whatever but then when
you're just like stuck in the middle
you're just like
i think dad has a point
because he's gonna be like buying my
books and food and stuff
and my mom's just like
what a skunk i remember um
my mom wasn't gonna get a divorce and
like costume is trouble she's like i
just want to be like past this [ __ ] and
my family member was like you got to ask
him for something because like you know
he's going to cost some money so she
goes all right and then so um i was like
he's dropping right and she's like
basically she's like all i'm asking for
is like 200 bucks a month for a little
bit of help and he goes are you trying
to bleed me dry woman
about like 200 bucks
[ __ ] membership and i was like [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
i was like i sell [ __ ] weed and i
could make more than that [ __ ] no in a
week
and then like steve yeah literally
14 years old he's like that's four
piranhas i guess so
yeah that's true that's only four
piranhas i'm like
do you know he used to separate
i'm 14 years old and i can make more
than this [ __ ] face and i'm like 200
bucks a month it's not that much money
i was like holy [ __ ] what a [ __ ] dad
was a dead did he end up paying or your
mom didn't go through i think he did
reluctantly
and i think he stopped after like some
time damn it yeah he believed me driving
[ __ ] this guy
[Laughter]
you trying to bleed me dry woman that's
so [ __ ] funny over 200 bucks whatever
he was super [ __ ] rich and he was
like [ __ ] two hundred dollars damn keep
your money man you gotta throw fits how
do you think there's kelly clarkson
meeting with
dude what will you five a month that's
not your
so they're um also those totals they um
that she's paying monthly they that's
not forever obviously like uh the um i
think the larger sum the one that's like
the hundred something thousand is only
for like
some amount of months up until the oh
only a few months but the child supports
up until the kids this but then the
spousal support which is 115k that's the
spousal support doesn't last forever oh
yeah cause that's for the the loser ass
husband
that's for
ranch rick yeah
the leech
but still 40 g's or 50 g's a month they
ain't happy dude you could tell until
the kid's 18 yeah it looks like max
kellerman
that's good moolah wish that kid the
best wait he's making more on child
support than he does on his career
that's wild dude
i still don't believe that 10k a month
absolutely not supports free right
that's what i'm saying i don't believe
i mean no grown man in the music
business he should just sell piranhas
you just know for sure that he he did
some clever [ __ ] and is able to hide
assets i feel bad for this guy dude good
man that's there's no one he's making
less than all of us
on paper which is
technically he's killing that's because
he's got 19 million dollars
[Music]
hi